bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
on va faire une vidéo qui m'a beaucoup
été demandée un petit un petit avis
critique sur le documentaire cave of
bones documentaire Netflix réalisé en
2023 key of bones qui a probablement été
traduit par grottocement mais un
documentaire Netflix qui a déjà une
réputation de documentaire pas top entre
apocalypse et Cléopâtre on a eu que du
bon documentaire récemment sur Netflix
donc évidemment vous avez été nombreux à
me demander mon avis sur ce documentaire
puisque vous vous doutez bien que il y a
peut-être quelque chose qui va pas on
est bien d'accord que si vous me
demandez mon avis c'est que de base vous
avez reniflé que quelque chose sentait
pas très bon aujourd'hui je vais vous
donner une petite mise au point sur ce
documentaire alors j'en ai déjà parlé
avec Thomas Durand sur sa chaîne la
tronche en biais donc je vous invite à
aller voir cette vidéo pour en savoir
plus ce que je vais faire aujourd'hui
c'est un résumé finalement des arguments
et surtout quelque chose de plus
focalisé sur le documentaire et un peu
moins sur la littérature scientifique
puisque avec Thomas on a surtout parlé
de la littérature scientifique
alors déjà qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
documentaire de quoi il parle si vous
l'avez pas vu et que vous cherchez à
vous faire un avis c'est un documentaire
qui parle donc de l'aventure du
paléoanthropologue liberger à la
découverte finalement des des traces
d'intelligence on va dire d'une espèce
d'hominidés qui s'appelle homonalédique
et au Money pour rappel c'est un
hominidé qui a été découvert en 2015
enfin du moins l'annonce de la
découverte a été faite en 2015 c'est un
hominé qui vivait il y a entre 200 000
et 300 000 ans donc il était
contemporain des tout premier Homo
sapiens en Afrique au Mona Lady ayant
été découverte dans une seule et unique
grotte en Afrique du Sud pour l'instant
donc homonaledi vivait il y a entre 200
et 300000 ans dans une grotte pour
l'instant mes documentée que dans une
grotte en Afrique du Sud c'est un
hominidé qui se caractérise par la
petite taille de son cerveau et qui va
lente à au cerveau de Homo habilis
environ 600 cm3 de volume et par une
morphologie du pied qui elle par contre
est totalement similaire à celle d'Homo
sapiens donc il a un peu cette
assemblage de caractères très bizarre
entre petits cerveau relativement
primitif mais morphologie du pied très
dérivé la morphologie de la main est
tout aussi bizarre avec un pouce qui est
relativement long donc qui indique une
capacité à saisir des objets la fameuse
prestigation grip la trappe de précision
au niveau des pouces mais en même temps
les les phalanges sont arqués ce qui
indique une certaine rétention encore
une fois de la faculté primitive à
pouvoir s'accrocher aux branches
donc on a cette assemblage de caractères
chez o'monaledi et donc on a cette
immense mystère à propos de monnaie on a
vraiment là pour le coup une question
qui n'a pas de réponse scientifiquement
parlant pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne le
trouve que dans une seule grotte et
surtout pourquoi est-ce qu'il est tout
seul dans cette grotte au moins n'allait
dit est le seul hominaire qu'on trouve
dans la grotte rising star
dans laquelle il y a plusieurs chambres
dont la chambre d'inaldi et la chambre
les saisies et dans ces deux chambres à
l'intérieur de cette grotte on a trouvé
que au money et ça c'est extrêmement
bizarre parce que bah on s'attendrait à
trouver sachant qu'on est il y a 200
300.000 ans on s'attend à trouver du
Homo sapiens sarchaïque et sachant qu'on
est dans le en Afrique du Sud dans un
système de grotte on s'attend à trouver
un échantillonnage de tout ce qui vivait
à l'époque pourquoi est-ce qu'on a que
aumôna Lady alors qu'à la même époque
vivait des bovidés des chauves-souris
etc etc il y a une immense quantité
d'animaux qui se retrouvent normalement
préservé dans un système de grotte comme
celui de Rising Star et c'est ce qu'on
trouve par exemple à sterfontaine à
chromdry un Swart Croze qui sont des
grottes qui sont juste à côté de la
grotte rising star
et pourtant on a que au monaladi donc on
a ce problème en fait qui a que aumônaie
dans cette grotte et pourquoi et bah
pourquoi on ne sait pas c'est une
question pour laquelle on n'a pas encore
de réponse et donc ce documentaire nous
propose des réponses à cette question
nous propose au moins quelques petits
idées on va dire propose des idées pour
nos explications évidemment l'idée qu'il
propose ce documentaire et qui a
certainement fait réagir pas mal d'entre
vous c'est elle propose que aux Mona
Lady pratiquait des rites funéraires ce
qui est pas complètement insensé quand
on y réfléchit puisque un assemblage
mono-spécifique d'être humain ça
s'appelle un cimetière
quand on trouve que des êtres humains
empilés à un endroit
et qui a rien d'autre empilé au même
endroit
c'est nous on appelle ça un cimetière
donc ça ça a quand même du sens de se
poser la question mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'il y a aumôna lady et ça a du sens
d'y répondre bah peut-être parce que
c'était un cimetière donc ça déjà c'est
l'approche que propose ce documentaire
donc on va se documentaire va explorer
les signes d'intelligence d'homonale et
dit et notamment pour nous diriger vers
la réponse au monalédies pratiquée des
rites funéraires donc il va nous
présenter des preuves d'intelligence de
Mona Heidi pour nous convaincre que aux
Mona Lady était capable de pratiquer des
rites funéraires ce qui expliquerait
pourquoi aumône-allédi est la seule
espèce qu'on trouve dans le système
Rising Star ce que le documentaire
d'ailleurs oublie de rappeler ce que ou
du moins n'insiste pas suffisamment
dessus donc ça c'est important de le
rappeler pour moi maintenant alors quel
est mon opinion sur ce documentaire
alors vous connaissez évidemment mon
désamour pour les documentaires sinon
vous ne m'auriez pas demandé mon avis je
n'aime pas le format documentaire je
trouve que le format documentaire
particulièrement quand il s'agit de la
paléontologie est un format en crise on
ne sait pas en paléontologie faire je ne
sais pas pourquoi je ne saurais
l'expliquer mais on ne sait pas faire de
documentaire à propos de la
paléontologie et de l'évolution sans
transformer ça en une espèce de grand
spectacle et moi quand je regarde la
documentaire je n'y vois que des
mensonges je n'y vois que des gens en
train de prétendre être en train de
travailler en train de faire semblant de
travailler ils font semblant de pianoter
des trucs sur ordinateur ils font
semblant de creuser je ne vois que des
gens qui font semblant de faire leur
métier pas des gens en train de faire
leur métier on vous met en scène des
moments de révélation qui n'ont jamais
eu lieu dans la réalité bref c'est c'est
pas que spécifique à ce documentaire
c'est tous les documentaires et c'est
encore pire avec les documents fiction
bon bref un film au moins ça le contrat
c'est que c'est censé vous divertir et
que c'est censé être un mensonge c'est
pas censé être une histoire qui s'est
réellement produite avec les
documentaires c'est un pardonnable donc
j'ai un certain des amours pour le
format documentaire pour pour ces
raisons là ceci dit pour un documentaire
ce n'est pas un mauvais documentaire
c'est assez agréable à regarder ça se
regarde d'une traite sans trop de
problèmes on ne s'ennuie pas on voit les
découvertes donc c'est scénarisé
évidemment donc on voit les découvertes
se produire ce produit dans un certain
ordre parce que c'est le scénario qui a
dit que les découvertes devaient se
produire dans cet ordre là pour produire
une histoire donc c'est ça on vous
raconte une histoire et c'est ça qui me
plaît pas dans les documentaires c'est
cette histoire de pourquoi ne pas
raconter la vérité alors que c'est ça le
contrat bref donc on vous raconte cette
histoire assez assez simplement assez
efficacement c'est pas désagréable à
regarder il y a quelques erreurs ici et
là comme par exemple le moment où on
vous montre le cap enfin la ville du Cap
mais quand vous écris en dessous
johannesbur on reconnaît pourtant bien
la montagne de la Table dans l'image
mais bref il y a quelques erreurs par-ci
par là il y a des stocks foutage ce sont
ces images libres de droit ou que les
documentaristes achètent pour compléter
certains vides dans le documentaire on
voit des stocks footage assez évident
donc un montage qui a pas été très bien
fait qui est pas fait aussi bien qu'il
aurait pu l'être du moins dans bref il y
a des raccords qui sont un peu qui sont
un peu comme ça un peu pétés mais disons
que globalement le documentaire se
regarde assez simplement donc en tant
que documentaire c'est pas un mauvais
documentaire à mon avis par contre au
niveau de ce qu'il raconte ce
documentaire il nous resserre encore une
fois le cliché de on est en train de
réécrire l'histoire de l'homme et ça on
nous le ressort mais si vous regardez
l'actualité scientifique si vous suivez
l'actualité scientifique sur les réseaux
sociaux sur Internet n'importe où tous
les 15 jours on nous réécrit l'histoire
de l'humanité la paléontropologie est en
train de mourir sous les coups de sa
propre communication tous les 15 jours
on nous dit et vous savez quoi en fait
on n'a rien compris et c'était comme ça
que ça s'est passé
et si vous voulez la première fois ça va
la deuxième fois bon on commence à se
poser des questions mais au bout de la
troisième fois de la 5e fois de la 20e
fois que les gens sont confrontés à
cette idée
on a encore réécrit l'histoire de
l'humanité
évidemment que les gens vont se dire
mais oui mais du coup on sait jamais on
sait jamais on n'a jamais su ce qu'il se
passait en réalité tous les 15 jours on
change d'avis il y a les gens ils se
font des petites batailles d'ego ils
font des petites batailles des petits
combats de d'autorité et puis c'est tout
c'est ça la paille anthropologie c'est
une cour de récréation ou les gens se
battent à coup de zob pour savoir qui
qu'elle a la plus grosse et en fait on
ne sait rien de ce qui se passe voilà
l'idée qu'on est en train d'engrainer
d'insérer à grands coups de marteau tous
les 15 jours dans la tête des gens en
leur répétant sans cesse on est en train
de réécrire l'histoire de l'humanité
tous les 15 jours on vous réécrit
l'histoire de l'humanité ça suffit
utiliser autre chose pour accrocher
l'intérêt des gens les gens sont
intéressés par la Paléo anthropologique
si on ne peut pas faire confiance aux
simples fait que l'évolution humaine et
que les dinosaures sont capables juste
par eux-mêmes de susciter de l'intérêt
où va-t-on où va-t-on cette la
paléonthropologie est en train de mourir
sous les coups de sa propre
communication que ce soit donc les
chercheurs ils sont bien je veux dire la
parler anthropologie en tant que champ
de recherche il est pas en train de
mourir mais c'est la façon dont les
chercheurs communiquent la façon dont
les médias communiquent à propos de la
recherche la façon dont ces
documentaires systématiquement vous
racontent une histoire différente alors
que fondamentalement depuis les années
50 depuis qu'on a des bunké l'homme de
pildown depuis que les chercheurs les
paléontropologues eux-mêmes ont des
bunké l'homme de pildon dans les années
1950 l'histoire de l'évolution humaine
fondamentalement n'a pas subi de
réécriture on n'a pas réécrit l'histoire
de l'évolution humaine ces derniers 50
ans on a fait que trouver de nouveaux
fossiles il n'y avait aucune raison que
ces nouveaux fossiles renforcent
l'histoire qu'on connaissait déjà et
pourtant à chaque fois ces nouveaux
fossiles se sont rajoutés à cette
histoire ce sont très bien articulés à
cette histoire et pourtant à chaque fois
on vous a fait croire que l'histoire de
de notre évolution était réécrite et ça
c'est c'est de la folie c'est vraiment
de la folie c'est quelque chose qui est
en train de tuer la confiance que les
gens pourraient avoir envers la
paléontropologie on ne peut plus avoir
confiance en ce qu'on nous raconte en ce
que nous raconte les scientifiques on
est sur une crise de confiance voilà
c'est la crise c'est la fameuse crise de
confiance envers les autorités
scientifiques et comment voulez-vous
qu'il n'y ait pas crise de confiance
envers les autorités scientifiques
puisque on ne fait que vous rabâchez
sans cesse que on ne sait rien et qu'il
faut tout réécrire à chaque fois donc ce
documentaire tombe dans ce piège en vous
disant qu'encore une fois si au
monaladies intéressé mort et si au Mona
Lady pratiqué des formes d'art et si au
Mona Lady avait domestiqué le feu et si
aumône allez dit fabriquer des outils
alors ça change absolument tout ce qu'on
croyait savoir sur l'évolution humaine
bah non non et du coup je vais
m'employer maintenant pour les quelques
prochaines minutes à essayer de vous
expliquer pourquoi est-ce que ça ne
change pas pas tant que ça ce qu'on
croyait savoir et pour ça on va
commencer déjà par dire que ce
documentaire sur aumône-allédi le key of
bones ce documentaire était accompagné
de trois préprints qui ont été publiés
dans une revue qui s'appelle iLife donc
j'ai une revue relativement prestigieuse
toute science confondues mais par contre
les les papiers en question ce sont que
des préprints c'est-à-dire qu'ils n'ont
pas encore été acceptés pour publication
donc si vous voulez la revue n'a pas
encore dit bon bah ça va on le publie et
la raison pour ça c'est parce que les
reviewer c'est-à-dire les autres
scientifiques qui ont lu ces articles
afin de valider ou non leur contenu les
autres scientifiques ont dit non la
science n'est pas encore suffisamment
bonne dans ces articles ce qu'ils ont
fait dans ces articles ce n'est pas à la
hauteur des standards de la qualité
qu'on s'attend à trouver dans des
articles qui prétendent les choses
qu'ils essayent de prouver en fait donc
il n'apporte pas des preuves
suffisamment robustes la méthodologie
n'est pas suffisamment abouti
pour démontrer les choses qu'il
prétendent vouloir démontrer donc le feu
les gravures les outils et les
comportements funéraires tout ça ça
demande une quantité de preuves et
surtout une qualité de preuve et une
méthodologie irréprochable afin d'être
démontré et cela n'était pas suffisant
d'après les reviewer les auteurs n'ont
pas encore proposé de correction pour
prendre en compte ses commentaires qui
ont été faits par les reviewer donc au
moment où je vous parle il y a encore
une chance que des corrections soient
proposées soit
appliquées à ces articles pour que les
standards en question soit acquis
généralement ça va généralement ce qui
va se passer c'est que en appliquant les
corrections en question la méthode va se
raffiner l'épreuve vont se renforcer
mais aussi du coup les conclusions vont
s'amener ce qui était autrefois des
gravures d'homonaledies par exemple
peuvent devenir des gravures oui mais de
qui pas forcément de monnaie peut-être
d'Homo sapiens c'est à dire que des
conclusions qui étaient un peu un peu
très tape à l'oeil à la base vont
devenir des conclusions qui seront
beaucoup plus tempérées donc
généralement c'est ça qui se passe au
moment de de la review normalement le
grand public n'a pas accès à cette phase
là mais la revue illife a décidé de
publier des prêts et les reviews on a
donc trois articles pas encore accepté
par la communauté scientifique ni par le
journal dans lequel les articles ont été
proposés ces trois articles dans l'état
où ils sont
apportent les document les documents
nécessaires pour soutenir ce qui est
proposé dans le documentaire ce sont
exactement les mêmes preuves qui sont
proposées dans le documentaire et dans
les articles sauf que dans les articles
il y a évidemment beaucoup plus de
détails et ça permet du coup d'avoir un
bien meilleur avis de quelle est la
force de ces de ces de ses preuves
quelle est la validité de ses preuves
donc on a ces trois articles qui vont
nous présenter les preuves que nos Mona
Lady utilisaient du feu les preuves
commona Lady faisait des gravures
l'épreuve comme on avait dit fabriquer
des outils et les preuves que aux Mona
Lady pratiquer des comportements
funéraires des comportements post mortem
devrais-je dire parce que funéraires ça
implique déjà
sophistication du du comportement qu'on
aura beaucoup de mal à établir quoi
qu'il arrive dans un registre
archéologique donc on va peut-être
plutôt parler de comportement post
mortel comme on le fait par exemple pour
les animaux pour les dauphins pour les
éléphants pour les chimpanzés on parle
de comportement post mortem quand ils
sont à certaines intérêt pour leur
défunt quand les chimpanzés par exemple
quand une maman chimpanzée garde son
bébé dans les bras pendant 15 jours
après sa mort par exemple c'est un
comportement post mortem ça veut c'est
pas forcément un comportement funéraire
mais c'est un comportement qui dénote
d'un intérêt pour un proche malgré le
fait qu'il soit mort donc voici pour la
terminologie maintenant passons aux
arguments au Mona Lady était-il capable
de faire du feu la réponse est peut-être
ben oui peut-être d'un que non mais en
tout cas la preuve n'est pas dans ces
articles en termes de preuve
d'utilisation du feu dans la grotte
Rising Star ces articles nous nous
présentent aucune preuve il cite un
autre article qui est lui-même un
article publié par New Scientist donc
c'est une c'est une revue de
vulgarisation scientifique ce n'est pas
une véritable revue scientifique donc il
cite New Scientist New Scientist
lui-même cite une conférence que
liberguer a donné qui est le elle-même
qui elle-même n'est pas une conférence
scientifique mais une conférence grand
public donc en réalité il n'y a pas de
science derrière l'utilisation de feu
chez o money tout ce qu'on a c'est ce
qui nous est montré dans le documentaire
à savoir oui il y a du il y a du charbon
dans la grotte Rising Star quel âge à ce
charbon est-il suffisamment vieux pour
être attribué à aumônaie n'est-il pas
trop vieux pour être attribué à aumônaie
a-t-il seulement été fait par homonaledi
il faudrait pouvoir répondre à toutes
ces questions pour pouvoir dire ce feu
au monde allez dit faisait du feu et
encore une fois ce n'est que du charbon
on n'est pas dans le cas on n'est pas
forcément en tout cas je n'ai pas vu
évidemment je n'en sais pas plus que
vous donc je ne peux pas affirmer qu'il
s'agit réellement d'un foyer d'un feu
contrôlé il peut tout aussi bien s'agir
de charbon de bois qui ont été rapportés
dans la grotte par un homonaledi ou
n'importe quel autre espèce
qui tenait un bâton enflammé bâton qui
aurait été naturellement enflammé par un
orage par exemple je rappelle que on est
dans les alentours de Johannesburg il y
a énormément d'orages c'est une des
zones du monde où il y a le plus
d'orages il y a énormément d'incendie
dues aux orages dans la région de
Johannesburg donc pour voir attribuer
une utilisation du feu à aumônaie ça
demande au moins de dater les charbons
et ça c'est assez facile à faire avec le
carbone 14
peut se faire avec d'autres techniques
évidemment mais en tout cas ça demande
au moins de dater le charbon pour être
bien sûr que ça correspond à l'époque ou
au Mona Lady occupait la grotte
c'est-à-dire entre 200 et 300 000 ans or
ils n'ont pas fait ça donc c'est
vraiment l'étape numéro 1 de démontrer
comme on avait dit est responsable du
dépôt de ce charbon ça n'a pas été fait
et il y a aussi l'idée que bah il faut
aussi prouver que ce soit un feu
contrôlé pour ça il faut une étude ta
phonomique extrêmement détaillée c'est
extrêmement compliqué de démontrer
qu'une qu'un usage du feu était contrôlé
généralement ça passe par deux choses
d'une il faut trouver il faut genre une
rangée de cailloux qui délimite une
sorte de rond à l'intérieur duquel on va
avoir ce feu ça c'est le minimum une
rangée de cailloux ou alors un petit
trou qui a été creusé pour mettre le
bois à l'intérieur et puis surtout il va
falloir montrer l'existence d'un usage
répété du même endroit pour faire du feu
si on a un usage répété du même endroit
pour faire du feu donc plusieurs avec du
feu de du charbon à l'intérieur alors là
on va pouvoir compenser à accumuler de
bonnes preuves qu'il y avait un usage
contre les du feu ça n'a pas encore été
fait avec au money donc au moment où je
vous parle et au moment où je
documentaire sort on n'a pas de preuve
d'usage contrôlé du feu par monalité on
a même pas d'ailleurs de preuves de
d'usage du feu tout court par aumônaie
d'aucun intérêt que il fallait forcément
du feu pour aller dans la chambre
d'inhalie qui se trouve très
profondément dans la grotte Rising Star
et d'ailleurs le documentaire rend très
bien cette impression de profondeur
c'est c'est s'il y a bien une qualité à
ce documentaire c'est que ça nous donne
vraiment une idée de à quel point c'est
difficile d'accéder à la chambre
d'inaldi mais ça c'est aujourd'hui
ça ne veut pas dire que par le passé il
y a pas eu une autre ouverture
donc l'usage du feu non pas forcément on
n'est pas obligé d'avoir du feu pour
atteindre la chambre d'inhalie où tous
les cordes de monanédie se trouve
peut-être qu'avant il y avait une autre
entrée qui permettait d'aller dans la
grotte dans la chambre d'inaldi il y a
plusieurs petites preuves qui le
soutiennent la présence de descargots
dans les sédiments où on trouve au
moneydice les escargots ils ont
difficilement pu atteindre cet endroit
là tout seul en tout cas s'il y avait
pas une s'il y avait pas une autre
entrée
du manganèse il y a des dépôts de
manganèse sur les os qui tendraient à
suggérer que du lichen a grossi dessus
enfin que du lichen a grandi à pousser
sur les eaux ce qui veut dire que les
eaux étaient exposées à la lumière du
coup parce que sinon le lichen ne peut
pas pousser
et on a des chouettes on a retrouvé
quelques petits ossements de chouettes
dans la chambre d'inhalie pareil il est
chouette on pense pas qu'elles étaient
capables de voler aussi profondément
dans la grotte ce qui suggère du coup
qui avait peut-être une autre entrée
donc le feu est une condition non
nécessaire à l'accès à la chambre
d'inhalie alors passons maintenant au
gravure alors c'est gravure donc qui
selon le documentaire pourrait être une
forme d'art similaire à celle que Homo
sapiens et homonet harder talentis donc
sapiens l'homme moderne est Néandertal
pratiquait à peu près à la même époque
voire même un petit peu plus tard donc
ce qui ferait des gravures de monnaie
les plus anciennes gravures au monde
c'est quand même pas rien de le proposer
donc c'est pour arriver à démontrer
qu'on est face à des gravures pratiqués
par homonaledick et ce qui nous faut bah
déjà il faut arriver à démontrer que
c'est formes donc c'est gravure en forme
de hashtag en forme de très croisé
arriver à démontrer que c'est gravure ne
sont pas d'origine naturelle ça c'est le
premier niveau le deuxième niveau c'est
une fois que vous avez démontré qu'elles
ne sont pas d'origine naturelle que ce
sont bien des gravures faites
artificiellement par une main humaine il
faut arriver à démontrer que cette main
humaine n'était pas celle d'Homo sapiens
et ça c'est important on va le voir
pourquoi et ensuite il faut garder à
l'esprit que la pratique de l'art c'est
quelque chose enfin c'est quelque chose
qui en archéologie a une définition
assez différente de ce qu'on appelle la
pratique de l'art aujourd'hui ce qui
pourrait rendre c'est une telle
découverte donc des gravures de monnaie
pas si révolutionnaire que ça alors on
va explorer ces trois étages un peu plus
en profondeur donc déjà l'aspect naturel
des gravures c'est gravures sont-elles
réellement d'origine artificielle
d'après le documentaire d'après ce qu'on
peut voir dans le documentaire et encore
une fois c'est là que c'est intéressant
ça donne une idée en trois dimensions de
ces gravures contrairement aux articles
se prolonger dans la roche d'autres sont
à l'évidence d'origine artificielle il y
en a notamment une qui passe par dessus
un stromatolite ça on ne nous le dit pas
réellement en tout cas on assiste pas
beaucoup dessus dans le documentaire
mais il y en a effectivement certaines
qui passent par dessus des stromatolites
donc là on a vraiment des choses qui
sont qui coupent en fait d'autres
structures et qui sont du coup qui ne
peuvent pas être contemporaines
finalement de la roche elle-même donc ça
à la limite ça peut qualifier en tant
que gravure mais même si on arrive à
démontrer qu'il s'agit de gravures ça ne
veut pas forcément dire qu'elles
appartiennent à aumônaie et c'est là
qu'il va falloir toucher à quelque chose
qui s'appelle le principe d'actualisme
il y a une mode aujourd'hui notamment
dans les documentaires dans la
communication scientifique autour de
l'évolution humaine qui consiste à
déconstruire systématiquement Homo
sapiens donc dire que Homo sapiens ce
n'est pas le seul à faire si ou n'est
pas le seul à faire mi c'est à la mode
en ce moment
découvrir voilà les gens sont très
friands de découvrir que que on n'est
pas les seuls à être capable de faire ci
ou ça c'est ça vaut pour la Paléo
anthropologie mais ça vaut aussi
évidemment pour l'étude des primates on
est on est tous très très contents
d'apprendre que WoW en fait les Homo
sapiens ce n'est pas le seul à faire
telle ou tel comportement mais et là il
y a un gros mec il faut mettre on est
complètement dépendant du principe
d'actualisme on est complètement
dépendant du fait que Homo sapiens est
la seule espèce humaine aujourd'hui et
on ne peut rien faire contre ça c'est
une condamnation il n'y a aucun moyen
d'en échapper et comme je n'arrête pas
de le répéter ce n'est pas un problème
si ça n'a pas de solution il faut vivre
avec le fait est que pour interpréter
les comportements anciens de nos cousins
au mininet nous n'avons comme point de
repère que nous-mêmes
et éventuellement les chimpanzés si on
efface un comportement qui peut se
retrouver chez les chimpanzés on a que
ça pour travailler c'est le principe
d'actualisme c'est le fondement de la
paléontologie si vous rejetez le
principe d'actualisme vous ne pouvez pas
faire de paléontologie et la conséquence
de ça c'est que toute forme d'art que
l'on retrouve dans le registre
archéologique toute forme d'art doit
être par défaut attribué à Homo sapiens
jusqu'à preuve du contraire on ne peut
pas prouver qu'une forme d'art a été
pratiquée par une autre espèce que la
nôtre à cause du principe d'actualisme
tant qu'on n'a pas démontré tant qu'on
n'a pas apporté une preuve que c'est
impossible que cela est été fait par
Homo sapiens et dans le cas de Mona lédy
on a évidemment ce problème que
vivait en même temps que Homo sapiens
donc c'est très difficile de démontrer
que les gravures n'ont pas été faites
par Homo sapiens alors je suis
complètement en faveur de l'argument que
on ne trouve que au monde à l'édit dans
cette grotte il n'y a que au money dans
les sédiments qui composent la chambre
de Dyna Lady là où se trouve les
gravures enfin il y a la chambre
d'inhalides mais il y a surtout les
gravures sont surtout dans l'antichambre
qui se trouve juste avant la chambre
d'inhalie mais peu importe il n'y a que
au money qui se trouve fossilisés à cet
endroit-là de la grotte je suis d'accord
mais il ne faut pas oublier le principe
fondamental c'est pas parce que tu es
mort ici que tu as vécu ici et dans le
cas de monnaie 17 encore pire c'est ce
n'est pas parce que ton cadavre est ici
que tu es forcément mort ici et encore
moins que tu as vécu ici donc c'est un
problème on sait pas parce que on a les
squelettes de Mona l'EDI qu'on a
forcément la preuve qu'il n'y que
aumônaie ici alors certes je suis en
faveur de la du maximum de parcimonie en
disant bah s'il y a que des squelettes
de Mona Hedi d'où vous pouvez vous
sortir un homo sapiens de là oui mais
c'est sans oublier le problème que
peut-être et certainement il y a eu une
autre entrée dans la grotte s'il y a eu
une autre entrée dans la grotte et que
la grotte était plus accessible elle
était certes plus accessible à homona
Lady on est d'accord mais elle était
aussi plus accessible à d'autres espèces
notamment le contemporain et déjà
démontré intelligent Homo sapiens et ça
devient d'autant plus problématique
quand on sait que il y a eu des
spéléologues qui sont rentrés dans la
grotte Rising Star avant les
paléontologues qui aujourd'hui la
fouille c'est d'ailleurs l'espèléologue
eux-mêmes qui sont allés dire à
libergers qu'il y avait des fossiles
dans cette grotte donc ce n'est pas lit
burger qui a découvert la grotte ce sont
les spéléologues lit burgers a été le
premier en reconnaître l'importance
scientifique on ne lui retirera pas ça
mais la découverte elle en vient donc à
partir du moment où on sait comment ça
piace avait accès d'une façon ou une
autre à la grotte à un moment ou à un
autre de l'histoire ça devient très très
compliqué de dire que c'est gravure ont
été faites par homona Lady l'hypothèse
de base ce qu'on appelle le Nail
hypothésis en anglais l'hypothèse de
base doit rester par principe
d'actualisme que cette Homo sapiens qui
a fait ses gravures jusqu'à preuve du
contraire et qu'elle pourrait être cette
preuve du contraire et bien ce serait
par exemple de pouvoir dater ses
gravures de entre 200 000 et 300 000 ans
qui irait avec la chronologie de dépôt
des squelettes de Mona lédies ça veut
dire que c'est ça voudrait dire que
c'est gravures ont été faites en même
temps que les squelettes de Mona Letty
ce sont déposés dans la chambre juste à
côté donc les gravures dans
l'antichambre et les squelettes dans la
chambre juste à côté ça aurait au moins
une chance d'avoir été fait en même
temps par plus ou moins la même
population mais de toute façon et ça été
pointé du doigt par les reviewer dans le
cas des articles le problème c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas daté c'est ils n'ont
pas daté ces gravures les gravures d'une
c'est très compliqué à dater puisque
c'est jamais que des trous dans un mur
donc voilà une grattage dans un mur
c'est quasiment impossible à dater la
meilleure chance pour arriver à les
dater c'est la calcite donc la calcite
qui du coup se dépose petit à petit à
l'intérieur des grottes en formant les
stalactites et les stalagmittes elle
s'écoule aussi le long des murs en
formant ce qu'on appelle en anglais des
spéléo thèmes donc cette calcite qui se
dépose sur les murs en fait bah elle a
pu être gravée par qui que ce soit qui
est fait c'est gravures donc en faisant
ces gravures vous grattez une couche de
calcite et ensuite de la calcite
continue à se déposer sur le mur
par-dessus les gravures donc en fait
vous auriez une couche de calcite
qui aurait été gratté par la gravure et
une autre couche de calcite qui ensuite
aurait été couvert par la gravure ce qui
veut dire qui ont ensuite recouvert la
gravure pardon donc une couche de
calcite qui a été définitivement faite
avant la gravure puisque la gravure lui
est passé dessus et une couche de
calcite qui s'est déposée après la
gravure puisqu'elle passe par dessus la
gravure et en les datant c'est de
couches de calcite ce qu'on est capable
de faire là on pourrait donner un âge ou
au moins une fourchette d'âge à cette
assez gravure donc c'est je sais pas si
ça s'est produit dans la grotte dans la
grotte Rising Star je sais pas si dans
les gravures qu'ils ont il y en a
certaines qui répondent à ces critères
là s'il y en a certaines qui sont
passées au travers de de ce spéléo thème
à travers de la calcite et qui ont ou
qui ont même été recouvertes par de la
calcite
mais c'est vraiment le numéro 1 on va
dire c'est vraiment le réflexe numéro 1
quand on a des gravures et qu'on veut
les attribuer à une espèce qui a occupé
une grotte c'est d'arriver à dater ses
gravures et au moins de dire bon bah
c'est gravure ont été faites en même
temps que l'occupation de la grotte par
cette espèce en question là ils ne l'ont
pas fait encore une fois à l'heure
actuelle à l'heure où je vous parle à
l'heure des préprint c'est datation
n'ont pas été produites à l'heure où le
documentaire est sorti c'est datation
n'ont pas été faite donc l'attribution
de ces gravures hormonale Eddy au moment
où je vous parle n'est pas avéré et
ensuite le troisième niveau à la
discussion sur la pratique de l'art par
homonaldy c'est évidemment est-ce que
c'est si révolutionnaire que ça est-ce
que même si on arrive à démontrer que
c'est gravures ne sont pas naturelles
même si on arrive à dater ces gravures
pour dire qu'elles sont cocomutantes à
l'occupation de la grotte au moment où
on allait y est venu même quand on en
arrive là même un jour lit Burger et son
équipe en arrive là et on leur c'est
tout ce qu'on leur souhaite
est-ce que c'est si révolutionnaire que
ça bah justement on est on est en droit
d'en discuter parce que il y a eu
beaucoup de d'hypothèses de pratiques
artistiques chez des espèces qui ont
très largement précédé Homo sapiens
Néandertal et n'allait dit alors les
gravures les gravures on est d'accord
c'est que Homo sapiens c'est Néandertal
je suis d'accord avec ça mais des formes
d'art ça ne se limite pas qu'aux gravure
en archéologie on va considérer que une
expression artistique peut être
raisonnablement supposé si on efface à
un comportement non utilitaire donc non
utilitaire c'est-à-dire pas nécessaire à
la survie par exemple il y a 2,8
millions d'années 2,8 millions d'années
j'insiste sur la date c'est pas 200000
ans c'est 2,8 millions d'années un
nominé à transporter un caillou dans une
une grotte qui s'appelle la grotte de
macapantrat il a transporté un caillou
dans la grotte de macapantrat ce caillou
n'a pas été transformé en outil et ça
c'est peut-être l'expression d'une forme
d'intérêt pour ce que représentait ce
caillou autre que pour en faire quelque
chose d'utile donc quelque chose qu'on
pourrait rapprocher à une expression à
un intérêt pour du beau alors c'est
d'autant plus intéressant que ce caillou
ce n'est pas n'importe quel caillou
c'est le galet aux multiples visages le
fameux Pebble of manifaces de macapant
strat c'est un caillou qui a en fait une
pareille dolie de visage sur l'une de
ces sur l'une de ses surfaces donc cette
pareille dolid visage est peut-être la
raison pour laquelle
Australopithecus ou un très ancien une
très ancienne espèce du genre Homo comme
Homo habilis ils ont vécu à peu près à
la même époque entre à 2,8 millions
d'années donc c'est dur de dire lequel
des deux à transporter le galet mais en
tout cas ça veut dire que il y a 2,8
millions d'années il y a peut-être
quelqu'un qui a vu ce visage sur le
galet qui a dit non celui-là je vais pas
en faire un outil c'est une forme
d'intérêt qu'on peut qualifier de
proto-artistiques alors il y en a
d'autres qui ont proposé que il y avait
peut-être un intérêt rituel dû à la
couleur rouge du galet par exemple alors
les comportements rituels c'est un peu
la carte joker quand on sait pas
expliquer quand on sait pas expliquer
quelque chose mais voilà rituel et
artistique c'est pas forcément opposé
non plus donc certes on est peut-être là
à la limite de des définitions on est
vraiment dans cette zone
ultra où on est où il faut étirer les
définitions à foison pour arriver à
expliquer quelque chose mais voilà la
grande question c'est est-ce qu'un
comportement artistique à cette époque
si récente de 100.000 300 000 ans pour
au money est-ce qu'un comportement
artistique à cette époque est vraiment
si surprenant que ça chez une espèce qui
finalement a une taille de cerveau
comparable à homonel habilis est-ce que
c'est si surprenant que ça
la réponse est oui c'est assez
surprenant mais finalement quand on
cherche bien on trouve d'autres exemples
chez comme je disais chez voir
Australopithecus ou Homo habilis on en
retrouve d'autres exemples chez Homo
erectus au Moyen-Orient en Inde on a des
exemples de d'expression
proto-artistiques qui ont qui sont
référencés dans la littérature donc
c'est pas non plus complètement
révolutionnaire c'est intéressant c'est
nouveau c'est une c'est une forme
d'expression qui jusqu'à présent n'avait
été les gravures je veux dire c'est une
forme d'expression qui n'avait été
trouvée que chez Neandertal et sapiens
mais Néandertal et sapiens avaient un
ancêtre en commun qui avait aussi
peut-être cette capacité à exprimer des
à faire des gravures et cette ancêtre en
commun il a vécu il y a plus de il y a
plus de 600000 ans donc 600 000 ans
c'est beaucoup plus vieux comme on
allait dit et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
pas dire que ça réécrit complètement
l'histoire de l'humanité encore une fois
on raffine cette histoire mais on ne
révolutionne plus depuis les années 50
depuis que l'homme de pile Dawn a été
débunké bon maintenant la fabrication
d'outils alors si on trouvait des outils
de Money est-ce que ce serait réellement
révolutionnaire de la même façon pas
forcément homo floraisienne 6 a un
cerveau qui est si je me rappelle bien
même plus petit que celui de Mona Lady
et pourtant on a des outils qui sont
définitivement associés à homoflorésiens
6 on a des outils jusqu'à
3,2 millions d'années les premiers qui
sont des loméquoyens la culture l'homme
et croyenne on 3,2 millions d'années
donc homonaledy qui fabrique des outils
c'est pas si surprenant que ça après
c'est le niveau de perfectionnement des
outils en question qui va déterminer si
oui ou non on est face à quelque chose
qui est surprenant ou non mais là le
caillou qu'il nous montre dans le
documentaire et dans les et dans les
publications puisqu'il n'y en a qu'un
seul ce caillou qui est qu'ils appellent
stone to like donc c'est vraiment qui
ressemble à un outil si on traduit ça
c'est un caillou qui fait à peu près la
taille de d'une main quoi donc c'est un
caillou qui est quand même assez grosse
et pas très raffiné comme comme culture
si on admet que c'était un outil ce
serait pas un outil très très raffiné
donc je sais pas si surprenant que ça de
trouver ça chez homonaldi c'est même au
contraire plus surprenant qu'ils en ait
pas trouvé plus que ça mais bon ça
renforce l'idée que la chambre d'inhalie
n'était pas un lieu de vie où il
fabriquait des outils mais bel et bien
un lieu de mort un lieu où ils ont
proposé des cadavres le problème
principal avec cette pierre bah c'est
que ils ne l'ont pas dégagé donc elle
est toujours dans la roche pour
l'instant elle est dans la roche et la
roche en question elle est dans un
plâtre et ce plâtre il a pas été ouvert
donc pour l'instant on ne sait même pas
si c'est un outil pour ça il faut
arriver à voir qu'il y a eu des marques
de de choc sur l'outil il faut voir
qu'il y a eu des traces pour tailler cet
outil et ça on ne peut le voir qu'à
l'oeil nu il y a pas d'autres moyens on
ne peut pas voir ça dans le documentaire
on nous montre bien ça a été le plâtre a
été amené en France il a été scanné au
synchrotron de Grenoble par les
chercheurs français polta par le
chercheur français poltaforo et on nous
montre bien du coup que tout ce qu'on a
c'est un une reconstitution digitale
donc à un moment on les voit tenir
l'outil dans leur main mais en réalité
enfin on voit les burger je crois un de
ses collègues tenir l'outil dans leur
main mais en fait c'est une impression
3D qui le tienne ce n'est pas le vrai
outil donc ce qu'on voit dans le
documentaire c'est une impression 3D de
l'outil et ça ne permet pas de dire si
oui ou non l'outil a été fabriqué il
faut vraiment arriver à voir directement
sur l'outil les tailles de les traces de
taille en fait donc ça c'est ça c'est
important de bien se comprendre que pour
l'instant personne n'a vu de ses yeux
cet outil enfin ce soi-disant outil cet
outil n'est pas encore un outil même aux
yeux de lit burger même aux yeux de son
équipe
il ne s'agit pas d'une roche qu'on peut
qualifier d'outils c'est vraiment très
important à c'est à dire que même pour
cette équipe ce n'est pas un outil c'est
un rocher qui ressemble à un outil mais
pour l'instant on n'est pas capable de
dire si c'est un outil ou pas donc les
outils chez homologalesi pour l'instant
toujours pareil pas de preuve on attend
que ce que cette que ce plâtre soit
ouvert et que cette outil soit dégagé
afin de pouvoir l'étudier ça arrivera en
temps voulu je leur fais confiance de ce
point de vue là mais pour l'instant ce
n'est pas fait donc outil pour l'instant
à l'heure où georgée cette vidéo à
l'heure où le documentaire a été publié
la réponse est non mais ça viendra
peut-être finalement les comportements
post-mortem la grande question la
question finale la mère de toutes les
questions est-ce que aux Mona Lady
pratiquer des comportements post mortem
les autres arguments ne sont là que pour
dire comme on allait dit dans le
documentaire je veux dire les autres
arguments ne sont là que pour dire au
monde allez dit est intelligent il est
donc capable de comportement funéraires
c'est bien ça le message du documentaire
donc une fois qu'on a bien enfoncé le
clou de l'idée que malgré la taille de
son petit cerveau au monde allez dit
était une espèce intelligente on vient
discuter la possibilité d'un
comportement funéraire et ce qu'on nous
montre dans le documentaire et ce sur
quoi on assiste beaucoup dans le
documentaire c'est que il y a un trou
dans lequel apparemment un corps a été
plié et déposé donc c'est vraiment une
le corps est vraiment très compacté donc
on suppose à ce moment là une position
quasi fêtarde un corps qui est vraiment
replié sur lui-même et qui aurait été
déposé dans un trou et donc ce qu'on
nous montre dans le documentaire c'est
un peu le contour de ce trou qui est
censé nous convaincre qu'il s'agit d'une
tombe ça c'est la grande idée du
documentaire
personnellement je suis pas convaincu
par ça tout simplement parce que des
organismes roulaient en boule dans des
trous moi j'en vois tout le temps et ça
s'appelle des terriers dans le cas où là
où je travaille essentiellement on a des
roches qui datent du Permien donc c'est
des roches qui ont plus de 250 millions
d'années donc c'est quand même autrement
plus vieux comme on allait dit là il y a
aucune chance qu'il y ait eu des animaux
suffisamment intelligents pour faire des
tombes vous imaginez qu'à l'époque avoir
le cerveau de la taille d'une noix vous
étiez un génie donc dans ces roches du
carreau vous avez un cerveau de la
taille d'une noix vous êtes l'empereur
de la terre mais heureusement à l'époque
personne n'avait le cerveau de la taille
d'une noix donc vous avez des animaux
qui n'ont aucune chance de pratiquer la
moindre début de comportement post
mortem
et bien on trouve des squelettes dans
des trous enroulés sur eux-mêmes en
position quasi fatal ce sont des
terriers on trouve des terriers et donc
il s'agit de on voit bien je veux dire
il y a un trou on voit ce trou on voit
les limites de ce trou on voit le
sédiment qui a rempli le trou qui est
différent du sédiment qui entoure le
trou en fait donc on n'a pas le trou
réellement on a un moulage du trou fait
en sédiment mais ce moulage est fait
dans un sédiment qui est différent de la
roche qui est autour de ce trou
donc là j'essaye pas de vous convaincre
comme on allaitif faisait des terriers
c'est pas ça que j'essaye de dire ce que
j'essaye de vous ce ce dont j'essaie de
vous convaincre c'est c'est pas parce
qu'on a un squelette en position fœtale
dans un trou qu'on est forcément face à
une tombe et à l'inverse vous pouvez
avoir des comportements funéraires qui
n'impliquent pas de trouver une tombe
par exemple voilà la crémation la
crémation il y a pas de tombes et
pourtant il y a bien un comportement
funéraire évident
cet extrêmement difficile de montrer
qu'on est face à une tombe et c'est
encore pire quand il ne s'agit pas
d'Homo sapiens parce que quand il s'agit
d'Homo sapiens vous pouvez trouver un
corps opposition fœtale dans ce qu'il
ressemble à un trou qui a été ensuite
comblé par du sédiment évidemment on est
face à Homo sapiens Homo sapiens on sait
qu'il a des rites funéraires puisqu'on
les voit encore aujourd'hui donc c'est
assez facile de voir ça et de dire oui
ceci est une tombe mais maintenant
imaginez pour Néandertal vous déjà un
Néandertal position fœtale dans un trou
comment vous faites pour dire que c'est
un rite funéraire sachant que vous
n'avez pas de Néandertal aujourd'hui
pour comparer et bien c'est très
difficile et ça a mis plus de 150 ans
pour convaincre la communauté
scientifique commune néandertalensis
avec des rites funéraires et même là on
continuera il y aura des gens pour en
douter il y aura encore des spécialistes
pour en douter et même là il y aura des
gens pour dire oui ils pratiquait des
rites funéraires mais il a appris série
de funéraires de Homo sapiens
ce n'est pas une question facile le rit
de funéraire le rit de funéraire c'est
un cauchemar à démontrer c'est
extrêmement difficile et c'est encore
pire quand vous n'êtes pas face à Homo
sapiens parce que vous n'avez même pas
le principe d'actualisme pour vous aider
mais voilà si vous voulez démontrer
qu'une espèce autre Homo sapiens avait
un comportement post mortem vous allez
en chier des briques parce que c'est
hyper difficile à démontrer et le mieux
c'est encore de trouver un cas d'école
parfait une tombe absolument
parfaitement préservée oui je sais ce
n'est pas ça qu'ils ont trouvé mais du
coup le fait qu'il ne que ce n'est pas
ça qu'ils ont trouvé laisse la porte
ouverte à plein d'autres possibilités
c'est possible que il y a eu par exemple
une une dépression naturelle dans le
trou enfin dans la dans la grotte je
veux dire les dépressions naturelles
dans les grottes ça il y en a partout
c'est la grotte elle-même donc il y a
une dépression naturelle dans le
dans la grotte cette dépression
naturelle quand il y a de l'eau qui
remplit la grotte parce que c'est le cas
quand de l'eau remplit la grotte bah les
ossements sont soulevés et puis bah
quand l'eau évacue la grotte les
ossements se redéposent bah au niveau de
ses drains en fait au niveau de ses
creux parce que c'est là que la gravité
les amène tout simplement donc c'est
possible de ramener les ossements comme
ça naturellement vers l'endroit où la
gravité va les passer la gravité quoi
c'est tout c'est
le principe quoi donc ça ça peut arriver
que naturellement des ossements des
corps même des corps tout entier
flottent dans une grotte inondée puisse
se dépose ensuite naturellement dans à
l'endroit finalement où le plus bas de
la grotte donc vous allez avoir une
accumulation qui va ressembler à une
tombe puisque vous allez avoir une
accumulation de sédiments et une
accumulation de corps au même endroit
donc à ce point là au niveau des
comportements post-mortem bah l'argument
qui reste le plus convaincant en faveur
de comportement possiblement post mortem
ça reste toujours le fait que il n'y a
que au monde n'allait dit dans cette
grotte
alors comportement post mortem certes
mais est-ce qu'on est vraiment face à un
comportement funéraire voyez là là il va
falloir là c'est là que c'est important
de faire la différence en fait c'est que
vous pouvez avoir un comportement post
mortem sans avoir un comportement
funéraire comme je le disais une fausse
commune creusée dans les années 40 il y
avait pas de comportement funéraire il
balançait les cadavres sans en avoir
rien à cirer mais pourtant on est bien
face à un comportement post mortem donc
il faut faire très attention à ça
techniquement techniquement quand vous
jetez les autres poulets dans la
poubelle après votre repas c'est un
comportement post mortem vous faites
vous créez une accumulation d'ossements
qui va probablement fossilisé ou pas
peut-être un jour mais en tout cas vous
créez une arcue une accumulation
intentionnelle d'ossement mais ce n'est
pas un comportement funéraire donc c'est
là qu'il faut différencier comportement
post mortem et comportement funéraires
comportement post mortem je suis
d'accord il n'y a qu'un seul moyen
expliquer qu'il y est une accumulation
mono-spécifique de monaédie dans cette
grotte et c'est un comportement post
mortem je vois pas de cause naturelle
possible expliquant une telle
sélectivité mais par contre que ce soit
homona Lady ou homo sapiens ce qui est
balancé les Macchabées dans la grotte
c'est pas dit qu'il y avait un
comportement post mortem et même s'il y
a eu un trou c'est pas forcément ça qui
fait de ce comportement un comportement
post mortem même s'il y a une un trou
qui a été creusé pour disposer des corps
ça ne fait toujours pas de ça un
comportement post mortem et c'est là
justement que les outils et les gravures
deviennent importants si les outils et
les gravures avaient été étudiés
beaucoup plus en profondeur avant le la
publication de ces prêts et avant la
publication de ce documentaire Netflix
on aurait eu une histoire beaucoup plus
convaincante on aurait eu vraiment une
association
entre des comportements post mortem de
déposition artificielle de corps
domonaledie dans une grotte on aurait eu
accompagnant ses corps des gravures et
des outils donc du matériel déposé en
même temps que les corps et des
comportements périphériques à ce dépôt
de corps et là on aurait eu quelque
chose de très convaincant si et
seulement si c'est gravure et ces outils
avaient pu être étudié à fond donc c'est
là où justement où la communauté
scientifique a exprimé des regrets bon
sang on avait une histoire parfaite on
avait une histoire parfaite on avait les
gravures on avait les outils on avait le
comportement post mortem et cette
histoire a été un peu gâchée du coup
parce que publier trop vite alors les
burgers il a des défauts mais il a aussi
une énorme qualité c'est celle de
publier ses découvertes assez rapidement
de rendre public ces découvertes assez
rapidement donc contrairement à certains
chercheurs qui vont être très très
territoriaux et qui vont protéger leur
découverte et s'y accrocher et ne la
publier que en dernière recours s'ils
sont sur le point de mourir uniquement
les burgers lui quand il trouve il
publie voilà et tout le monde le sait
donc ça c'est bien c'est bien c'est le
principe de la publication de rendre
public c'est découvertes c'est le
principe de la science c'est la science
dans son expression la plus pure et la
plus belle mais là c'était peut-être un
peu trop vite là il y avait des choses
évidentes à faire avant la publication
comme dater les charbons pour bien être
sûr qu'ils étaient contemporains
d'aumona Lady dater les gravures pour
être sûr qu'elles étaient contemporaines
de Mona Lady déterrer l'outil pour
pouvoir bien déterminer qu'il s'agissait
bel et bien d'un outil qui a été disposé
avec le corps de façon peut-être
intentionnelle peut-être pas l'intention
c'est vraiment la chose la plus
difficile à déterminer dans le registre
archéologique et c'est bien pour ça
qu'il faut être très minutieux en
archéologie c'est que contrairement à la
paléontologie dans les dépôts
archéologiques il y a une
intentionnalité et c'est cette
intentionnalité qu'il ne faut pas rater
et c'est pour ça qu'il y aurait fallu
dégager cet outil pour justement
déterminer cette intentionnalité juste
avoir une pierre qui est vaguement dans
la région du bras pas dans la main comme
il le disent dans le documentaire c'est
quand on regarde les figures on voit les
figures des prêts on voit que c'est dans
la région vaguement du bras mais c'est
tout ce qu'on peut voir
pour déterminer cette intentionnalité il
y aurait fallu montrer qu'il s'agissait
bel et bien d'un outil quelque chose qui
a été intentionnellement taillé
j'entends
et tout ça toutes ces planètes ce serait
alignées pour former un cas concret de
comportement funéraire tombe ou pas
tombe et c'est là que ça devient
intéressant justement c'est que qu'on
ait eu ou pas un trou creusé pour mettre
un corps de Mona Lydia à l'intérieur en
fait en ayant déjà les outils et les
gravures à disposition et bien documenté
et bien daté on aurait déjà eu
suffisamment d'arguments pour dire ok là
on a un comportement post mortem qui se
rapproche d'un comportement funéraire
parce que dans la chambre d'inaldi et je
le répète il n'y a que au money et dans
la chambre d'inhalie vous avez ces corps
et qu'ils aient été enterrés ou pas ça
ne change rien au fait que si vous avez
de l'intentionnalité dans le dépôt de
ses corps enterré ou pas la chambre
d'inaldi devient une chambre funéraire
donc pour conclure ben on va garder un
oeil on va garder un oeil sur ce qui se
passe avec omona Hedi parce que à
l'évidence il se passe quelque chose et
personne n'est contre l'idée
puisse s'agir d'un comportement
funéraire mais en tout cas il y a une
frustration claire sur ce cas parce que
Ben tout était là en fait et ça a été un
petit peu rocher et je pense que c'est
de là que ça vient en fait cette
controverse autour de ces prêts prints
c'est ce sentiment de travail pas fini
et qu'on aurait aimé en fait mais de
toute façon le travail n'est pas fini on
en est qu'à l'étape des préprint encore
une fois il faut le rappeler et je ne le
rappellerai jamais assez
c'est pas du travail mal fait c'est du
travail pas fini mais c'est à l'évidence
pas fini puisqu'on en est qu'au préprint
donc peut-être que d'ici quelques mois
peut-être même d'ici quelques années
peut-être que ça prendra des années à
finir ses articles mais peut-être que à
la fin quand ces articles seront
terminés quand c'est prêt print seront
acceptées pour publication officielle
alors peut-être que là on aura une
histoire complète de Mona Lady et de
comment il se débarrassait de ses corps
ou comment au contraire il ne se
débarrassait pas de ses corps mais les
disposaient de façon intentionnelle et
respectueuse dans cette chambre
d'inhalidi mais en tout cas pour
l'instant on en est pas là et ce
documentaire n'apporte pas ses preuves
et ses préprints pour l'instant à l'état
où elles sont au moment où je fais cette
vidéo n'apporte pas de preuve suffisante
merci c'est tout pour aujourd'hui je
vous dis à très bientôt sur notre chaîne
salut